cBS chairman and CEO leslie moonves
isn't commenting this morning on new
allegations of sexual assault the Los
Angeles County District Attorney says a
woman came forward late last year
alleging multiple incidents from the
late 1980s and a Warner is here with
details of that investigation Anna good
morning
good morning Nora yeah the LA County
District Attorney's Office looked at
whether they could file charges but
prosecutors say the statute of
limitations had run out already
meanwhile the CBS Board of Directors is
facing mounting pressure to do more a
partially redacted document from the LA
County DA's office shows a Jane Doe
claim to have encountered Moonves
through employment in the television
industry the multiple incidents of
assault were alleged to have occurred in
1986 and 1988 when Moonves was working
at Lorimar television possible offenses
listed or forced oral copulation
indecent exposure and battery she did
not actually make those allegations to
police until late last year CBS News
confirmed that police interviewed
Moonves lawyer but never spoke to moon
vents the DA's office determined in
February the statutes of limitation have
expired the disclosure comes days after
a New Yorker article laid out
allegations by six women who claimed
Moonves sexually harassed them between
the mid 1980s and early 2000s four of
the women claimed Moonves forcibly
touched or kissed them these are
allegations that are very very heavily
corroborated author Ronan Farrow wrote
that New Yorker article but he tweeted
Tuesday that the new report from Los
Angeles appears to stem from allegations
not included in our story from a
different additional woman
Moonves has not commented on the latest
allegation but previously denied or said
he doesn't recall many of the details
from The New Yorker article he did
acknowledge there were times decades ago
when he may have made some women
uncomfortable by making advances after a
meeting the CBS Board on Monday
announced it's in the process of
selecting outside counsel to conduct an
independent investigation CBS News
received no response Tuesday when we
asked if that independent counsel has
now been chosen to not put Moonves on
leave
was shocking Richard Greenfield analyzes
media companies
he believes the board should have had
Moonves step aside during the
investigation it makes it that much more
challenging for employees to come
forward if he's still in that seat
verses on some form of administrative
leave now Moonves has previously said in
a statement that he has always
understood that no means no we reached
out to him along with every other CBS
board member yesterday about these new
allegations we didn't get any responses
however we learned from several sources
that individual board members have been
discussing this new information in phone
conferences as recently as last night
Moonves could speak further on Thursday
when the board releases earnings CBS
won't confirm whether he will be leading
the company's earnings call with
investors Alex thank you Anna